вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі Європа
Дякуємо що ви приєдналися до нас
сьогодні спочатку Нового року війна
Росії проти України триває із
невблаганною жорстокістю
особливо сильно постраждали місто Бахмут
на сході України та майже безперервні
артилерійські обстріли залишили місто
повністю зруйнованим російські війська
вже кілька місяців намагаються захопити
цей стратегічно важливий регіон
українські війська тим часом відбили
багато інших населених пунктів
ця ситуація відрізняється від того як
російський президент Путін уявляв собі
хід своєї компанії в Україні його війна
зруйнувала незліченну кількість місць і
сіл убила тисячі мирних жителів поранила
був би була сотні тисяч солдатів як з
українського так і з російського боку в
умовах коли просування його військ
ходить нанівець а російська економіка
сильно постраждала питання залишається
відкритим що виграв від усього цього
Путін чи російське населення багато хто
в Україні все ще підтримує свого
президента і війну але є і супротив
вони скандують свободу спочатку тихо
потім голосніше відколи почалася війна
такі видовище стали рідкістю
демонстрації та акції протесту
заборонені судові засідання дають
опозиції один з небагатьох шансів
зустрітися
я простою одну хвилину Після чого в мене
буде адміністративний штраф на 10-20 50
тисяч і ці гроші підуть на цю ж саму
війну але я приходжу сюди щоб хоча б
побачити тих хто думає так само як я
тільки негатив зараз пишуть скрізь про
Росію але насправді це не так у Росії
дуже багато людей які проти всього що
відбувається тут зараз
людей прийшло небагато але все ж близько
сотні чекають коли їх допустять до зали
суду зрештою вирок який тут мають
оголосити стосуються війни
Ілля Яшин Засуджений до восьми з
половиною років колонії за звинуваченням
у дискредитації військових
у своєму прямому ефірі він обговорював
Бучу і показав що пишуть про війну за
межами Росії
не хвилюйтеся казав Яшин зі скляної
камери якщо Хтось думає що Путін буде
правити ще 8 років то він дуже великий
оптиміст
але приводів для оптимізму мало опозиція
здебільшого була ув'язнена або вигнана з
країни
російським ЗМІ дозволено зображати війну
лише як успіх країна здається оповита
туманом брехні та невизначеності навіть
один із колишніх спічрайтерів президента
Путіна зараз живе у вигнані абаз гальяму
приїхав багато років тому він каже що
війна була найбільшою помилкою Путіна
вона змінила все для Росії
вважався великим правителем людина яка
однозначно сприймалася як один із
найсильніших правителів у світі
таким жорстоким і не сильним а не тлі
Зеленського він звісно абсолютно з бляхи
проте Путін як і раніше міцно контролює
ситуацію навіть коли з його власного
табору лунає дуже обережна критика
критика відступу з Херсона які Всього за
кілька тижнів до цього Росія анексувала
всупереч міжнародному право і критика
провалу часткової мобілізації
у Кремлі Путін нагороджує медалями
солдатів які відзначилися під час його
так званої спеціальної військової
операції
але на самовпевненому фасаді з'являються
тріщини Путіну Все частіше доводиться
пояснювати свої методи ведення війни
навіть коли він випиває ігристе і знову
спеченими героями
ось зараз багато шуму з приводу наших
ударів по енергетичні інфраструктурі
сусідньої країни сусідні
сторони так ми робимо це
А хто почав хто вдарив по мосту по
Кримському
війна приносить Путіну дуже мало користі
а Росію що менше як бачать навіть його
прихильники
предмети розкоші не єдині товари які
зникли з полицю центрів Москви санкції
відчуваються по всій країні майже всі
іноземні автовиробники зникли
цей колишній завод Renault повернувся до
виробництва вітчизняної марки Москвич
Єгор рекламують як щось на зразок
суперкару зробленого у Росії насправді
Це точно копія китайської моделі загалом
китайські та російські автомобілі Це
єдині нові моделі у наявності
[музика]
Незважаючи на це економіка Росії
розвивається краще ніж очікувалося каже
Александра Прокопенко колись вона була
радницею Центрального банку Росії зараз
вона у вигнанні
захід обіцяв що будуть смертельні
санкції які рознесуть російську
економіку на шматки і в цілому були всі
шанси так зробити
анішим союзником Володимира Путіна ніж
генерали якби ембарву на російську нафту
і газ було введено весною потім не
отримав би додаткових доходів але зараз
у Росії є гроші на продовження цієї
воєнної авантюри у 2023 році
і схоже саме таким був план
парад історичної військової техніки у
Москві нинішня війна спрямована не лише
проти України ворог - це захід у всіх
відношеннях Путін ніби хоче раз і
назавжди довести перевагу російською
культури
Незважаючи на це його колишній
спічрайтер каже що він не увійде в
історію як позитивна фігура
він мав піти залишивши після себе міцний
режим а режим слабшає він точно його не
переживе щоб бути позитивним героєм І
потрібно було піти у 2008 році і вже не
повертатися після Медведєва ну або піти
в 2018 а не переобиратися на останній
термін
хор співає стару Червоноармійську пісню
про священну війну для нього Тепер у
Путіна немає шляху назад ніхто не знає
чи шкодує він про свою спеціальну
військову операцію чи ні але його власна
доля залежить від неї і від її
результату
люди вкрай стурбовані цим конфліктом
країна Член Європейського Союзу колись
була Радянська Республікою тож має
спільне минуле з Росією вона ж
кореспондент поїхав туди щоб зустрітися
з ткачем янісом розентальцем які разом
своєю сім’ї живе невеличкому містечку а
бабці ємс напад Росії на Україну вже
змінив життя сім'ї розентальців речі
стало дорожчими Але на відміну від
більшої частини Європи у латвій ці є
інша проблема близькість до великого
сусіда
Яніс розентальси з Латвії в середньому
вручну честь 7 метрів льону задає
і з цього виходить близько 8 шарфів
узимку яні та його дружина Лайла роблять
запаси Влітку вони продають свої вироби
на ринках по всій Європі
вони займаються цим бізнесом уже 20
років і все іде добре але коронавірусна
криза сильно вдарила по них А війна в
Україні ще сильніша ускладнила ситуацію
я ніколи не знаю чого очікувати на
заправці зараз
коли я вмикаю світло побачив як зникають
гроші
але це лише практичні проблеми
набагато гірше те що ми втрачаємо
людяність
на щастя янісу розентальсу допомагають
будувати дім друзі та родина
ціни на будівельні матеріали підскочили
більш ніж на 20%, а терміни завершення
будівництва доводиться пересувати знов і
знов
[оплески]
родина розентальців живе на заході
Латвії у крихітному селі абавці Яніс
насолоджується мальовничими краєвидами
двічі на день коли відвозить дітей до
школи і потім забирає їх
але не все так і делічно як може здатися
Латвія з її двомільйонним населенням
входить до п’ятірки найбідніших країн ЄС
вона мала цісні економічні зв'язки з
Росією протягом десятиліть і навіть Яніс
розентальц мав там клієнтів для свого
бізнесу але війна поклала цьому в
Україну
людям там Сподобалося те що Ми створюємо
але я не можу продати свою душу
тепер все просто сумно сумно і безглуздо
і багато інших почуваються так само як
Яніс із початком війни люди все більше
відчувають тривогу щодо свого східного
сусіда понад 30 років тому латвійці
проголосили свою незалежність від
Радянського Союзу але травма радянської
окупації все ще дуже глибоко вкорінена
близько чверті населення розмовляє
російською мовою переважно в столиці
Ризі І багато хто в Латвії симпатизував
Росії та політиці Кремля принаймні до
війни
[музика]
Зараз ми бачимо що відбулися величезні
зміни
а кількість людей які все що говорять
про Росію як про сусіда з яким можна
вести переговори чи торгувати
надзвичайно зменшуються
А всі інші Хто розуміє що відбувається
Ну вони ж бачать що Росія загарбник і що
ви повинні бути дуже обережними щоб не
мати української ситуації української
війни на наших кордонах і на нашій
території
розентальство вважають війну в Україні
жахливою але вони кажуть що хочу Україна
і недалеко вони все ще не відчувають що
їхня країна наражається на якусь велику
небезпеку вони вірять що НАТО їх
захистить І що напад Росії на Латвію
неминуча призведе до третьої світової
війни
[музика]
це якийсь апокаліптичне відчуття
вранці і просто не розумієш
читаєш новини і думаєш що чорт забирай
відбувається у цьому світі
але я все одно Сподіваюся на хороше
вважаю що треба робити все можливе не
втрачати людяності не втрачати віри
можливо це звучить по-дитячому Але я
вірю в дива
[музика]
Будинок розентальців знаходиться у
глибині західної Латвії
усього в декілька годинах їзди від
російського кордону на Сході
латвіті та росіяни мають спільну історію
яка тягнеться вглиб століть але їхнє
майбутнє тепер не певне
пішли на курси цієї ймовірність
наштовхнутися на корову і на вулиці і
навіть на пляжі оскільки на французькому
острові майже немає горош який бік
стримували корови бики і теляти ведуть
життя на абсолютній Свободі щоправда
Дехто з власників тварин не надто
переймається тим щоб точно вказувати
Скільки голів великої рогатої худоби у
їхньої власності це тому що за кожну
корову яку вони декларують Вони
отримують певні кошти від Європейського
союзу а тепер кожна корсиканська корова
повинна бути зареєстрована і фермери не
дуже цьому радіють
[музика]
корсиканські корови мають відносно
хороше життя часто вони навіть не
загороджені а вільно блукають де їм
заманеться тож Навряд чи хтось може бути
точно впевненим кому належить корова
і багатьох фермерів цілком влаштовує
така Свобода дій
плутани на обліку великої рогатої худоби
дозволяє їм звітувати перед ЄС про
більше поголів'я ніж є насправді каже
ліє Бастіан Неллі
вона поставила собі за мету навести
порядок у цьому хаосі
поголів'я великої рогатої худоби на
курси
ці отримують субсидії за кожну корову
тож Лія та її команда намагаються
встановити справжню кількість корів на
курсиці
Для цього вони імплантують худобі
мікрочіп які називаються болюс
ми використовуємо трубку щоб ввести болю
прямо в рубець або шлунок корови
під дією сили тяжіння болю залишається
там на все життя тварини
цього кілька секунд дискомфорту і корова
ковтає болюс
це швидко практично безболісно завдяки
Круглій формі його легко ковтнути
відтепер до танці нараховуватимуться
лише на корів з болюсним чіпом
власники цієї худоби в Долині траву
погодилися з таким рішенням
Я вважаю що це добре дійшло до того що
це необхідно було зробити
я можу пристосуватися і не роблю з мухи
слона Як деякі люди
але інші курси канці бояться втратити
щедрі субсидії ЄС
за оцінками загалом близько півтора
мільйона євро на рік на вигаданих корів
[музика]
вважається що з 50 тисяч задекларованих
голів великої рогатої худоби реально
існує лише близько половини у селі
Мар'яна мер вважає що це шахрайство було
очікуваним Він каже що є з кращим
виділив більше субсидій на овець та кіз
розподіляється деякі субсидії
Європейського Союзу призводить до того
що деякі фермери тримають худобу навіть
тоді коли у них немає необхідних площ
деякі фермери не мають успіху у
вирощуванні великої рогатої худоби
знайшли вихід у вигадуванні фіктивних
тварин на папері
Кожен з нас час від часу бере на себе
більше ніж може витримати
і люди в результаті вважають всіх
скотарів шахраями хоча це не так Але
серед них обов'язково знайдуться такі ми
їх бачили
не лише цифри стосовно великої рогатої
худоби не зрозумілі свині на Корці також
бігають вільно Але поки що ніхто не
пропонував живляти їм мікрочіпи
багато корсиканських фермерів
принципований довіряють владі у Парижі
та Брюсселі з їхніми кордонами правилами
та регламентами вони кажуть що ці
бюрократи все одно не розуміють реалії
тваринництва вони лише протегують
фермерам
[музика]
корова народжується на відкритому
повітрі вони живуть на волі а тепер вони
повинні ковтати якісь дивні чужорідний
предмет який вони не розуміють Мені не
подобається цей метод це диктатура Ми
живемо в диктатурі вільного ринку і у
мене складається враження що за мною все
більше і більше шпигують
наразі перші болюсні чіпи встановлені їх
можна зчитувати електронну
вони чітко ідентифікують кожну корову
ілліє бастіанелі налаштована
оптимістично
Ви можете бачити що багато фермерів
важко працюють і дійсно потребують цих
субсидій можливість краще ідентифікувати
худобу робить можливим виділення цієї
допомоги щоб краще розподілити її серед
тих хто її найбільше потребує
зрештою у реальному виграші залишаються
корсиканські корови адже ніхто не
вимагає щоб їх загородили як деінде і
позбавили свободи
[музика]
те що ви бачите тут прямо за мною це
дуже особливий банк в Італійській
столиці Риму особливий тому що він
розпоряджається не грошима а часу часом
який цінується його клієнтами не менше
ніж реальні гроші валюта - це робочі
години і обмінюючи ці години клієнти В
кінцевому підсумку якось сподіваємося
укладають угоду яка не тільки виглядає
справедливою але дозволяє їм відновити
зв'язок з людьми у своїй громаді і все
це за допомогою їхнього місцевого банку
часу
[музика]
Олександр збанку часу
але Сандро взяв собі дві години часу
для кого і для чого вони він ще не знає
куди мені йти
Це моя студія гарно
маурос Ще не закінчив облаштування своєї
нової квартири він гітарист але коли
справа стосується домашнього ремонту
його не можна назвати майстром він хоче
встановити полиці але боїться
просвердлити електричний кабель та на
щастя він член банку часу
для дрібнице ідеально
якщо тобі потрібно зробити щось маленьке
що ти не можеш зробити сам ти звертаєшся
до банку
і вони присилають когось
[музика]
Я працював на будівництві тож я робив
Всього потроху
електрика кладка
і тепер я можу знайти цю корисне
застосування
ми знаходимося у піньєту багато
національному районі ринок у багатьох
людей тут не так багато грошей і їх
з'їдає інфляція тому вони обмінюються
Доброго вечора синьйора Вера
я можу зайти
Як ваші справи
усе добре
80 років Вона проводить багато часу на
самоті
Мені потрібно мати дружню компанію
навколо
мій близький друг пішов із життя він
також був для мене своєрідним
сповідником у мене завжди був друг
сповідник
зараз Стефанія тут з годиною свого
дорогоцінного часу для бесіди та гри в
карти Стефанія і Вера також членкині
банку часу
Мені подобається пропонувати свій час
свою кампанію і розмови тим кому це
потрібно
за цими непримітними дверима знаходиться
офіс банку часу ідея в тому що всі води
діяльності коштують однаково і ними
можна обмінюватись якщо Олександру
працює на Мауро він може викупити цей
час у іншого учасника наприклад у
вересні в Італії є багато банків часу і
банк іньєту один із найстаріших Ілларія
фіксує всі відпрацьовані години Минулого
року їх було понад 600 і через кризу ця
цифра зростає
найбільше змінилися типи звернень
у нас стало більше Запитів на практичну
допомогу
ми важлива інституція для нашого району
це вкрай важливо для мене
життєво важливо
[музика]
Вера лише нещодавно переїхала до Риму і
знає тут дуже мало людей
окрім спілкування зі стефанією вона
хотіла б ще й обіграти її в карти але це
бажання Стефанія вже не готова так
просто виконати
можна багато чого здобути якщо скласти
комусь компанію
[музика]
80-річна Вера каже що не в змозі
сплатити борги за час але їй і не треба
на відміну від звичайних банків банк
часу не такий суворий до повернення
позик
добре дуже добре але Сандро теж закінчив
Якби він все ж просверлив кабель то вам
часу забезпечив би страховку Він не знає
що робитиме з отриманими двома годинами
часу але що важливіше Він познайомився з
музикантом який живе по сусідству Було б
класно зіграти разом колись так щось
організуємо
маура повертає свій Часовий борг того ж
дня викладаючи ввечері гру на гітарі в
банку часу
[музика]
і Стефанія викуповує свій кредит у Мауро
Вона працює вихователькою в дитячому
садку і грав карти з верою допомогла їй
дозволити собі Цей урок гри на гітарі Я
дуже схвильована не можу дочекатися коли
почну займатися на перше причастя мені
подарували білизну а моєму двоюродному
братові гітару Чесно кажучи я чекала
цього моменту 40 років
у банку часу віддаючи трохи отримуєш
багато натомість
[музика]
з кожним роком кататися на лижах че
сноуборді в Альпах стає все важче і
важче це пов'язано з тим що антропогенні
зміни клімату призводять до підвищення
температури в європейських горах Що
кращому випадку скорочує зимовий сезон а
в гіршому майже його унеможивлює навіть
у Швейцарії достатня кількість снігу вже
не сприймається щось належить і для
людей які заробляють на життя зимовими
спорту ситуація стає непростою
все що є багато способів насолодитися
горами такий був наш погляд на Європу
цього тижня якщо ви щось пропустили Чи
хочете поділитися цим епізодом онлайн ви
можете знайти його на нашому сайті від
імені цієї команди Дякуємо за перегляд
будьте в безпеці і до наступної зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ
2023 рік
[музика]